hey youtubers is Charlie so I finally
ranked my season six episodes just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
it yet I'll be talking about really
specific stuff so here we go okay so
let's talk about some season 6 episodes
they were all pretty strong but
sometimes what you would have is you
would have like amazing sequences in
certain episodes like the finale was
amazing but the first half of the finale
was like the best thing ever then it
kind of started to lose steam towards
the second half of the episode so you
know still an amazing episode but some
parts of it were just vastly better and
more interesting than the others so as
you tend to see in certain episode like
there's some episodes that just as a
whole or so much better than others but
then as you get towards the bottom of my
list like the episodes that I didn't
feel like we're quite as strong there's
still really strong moments in those
episodes like the Hound pay off with the
Brotherhood without banners with the
Arya stuff being not so satisfying so
you have like awesome Hound stuff not so
awesome Arya stuff so the way I did this
is that just did my favorite episodes
first and then it worked my way down to
my least favorite episodes first off
favorite episode hands down the door
episode 5 big Hodor payoff so they're
really like four or five different types
of scenes in any given TV show there's
like a plot base scene where they
advance the plot there's character based
scenes when you just have like amazing
moments between characters that don't
necessarily have anything to do with the
big macro arc then you have big payoffs
and then you have like combinations of
those different types of scenes so
episode 5 was kind of like a confluence
of delivering on big plot reveals like
this is how the White Walkers were
created this is why Hodor is named Hodor
the protagonist the episode brand caused
the death of the MVP of the episode so
he goes out with a blaze of glory maybe
to return as a white Walker everybody
wonders so episode 5 was just like this
really amazing character and plot driven
episode so you learn a whole bunch about
the mythology of Game of Thrones and it
delivers on big emotional moments like
Hodor so that's why in my mind it's like
the best episode number two of course
battle of the Basterds episode 9
probably the most cinematic episode that
they did all season this is actually I
think it's the only episode that they
submitted for like almost every single
Emmy category available like directing
cinematography pretty much anything that
you could win an Emmy for that happened
before the episode
so like when HBO was just like looking
at the raw footage of this they decided
that on a technical level on an
emotional level production level this
was their best episode of the season and
just on a production level I tend to
agree it is a fan who's trying to follow
the store like I'm mostly interested in
the story and what's going on with the
characters that's why episode 5 was my
favorite but episode 9 was a technical
masterpiece with a lot of great
character moments in it but largely it
was kind of like the stunt episode Dan
and Dave were like we wanted to do a big
pitch battle we hadn't really done an
episode like that so that's what this
was planned to be the real reason that
it's not tied for first is because it
throws logic under the bus in order to
get to some of those big payoffs in some
of the green-screen moments didn't
really land like Daenerys saying drew
Cara's like I wanted to give you this
really badass Terminator moment she's
acknowledging almost breaking the fourth
wall saying what a badass she is when
really I would have rather she like
screamed the line like screaming at them
as if she were the Mad Queen just kind
of playing with your head a little bit
there's this funny thing that they're
doing with Daenerys on the show where
they're making you think that she's this
really wonderful sweet character but she
also has a little bit of the Mad King in
her like a Targaryen edge to her but the
problem is that like is on a trope level
she's the childlike Empress so Emilia
Clarke isn't quite as good at delivering
that intensity in the way that Lena
Headey is like next season Lena Headey
is going to be the most amazing mad
Queen and there are mad Queen Daenerys
moments but Emilia Clarke isn't quite as
good at delivering them as Lena Headey
is she doesn't quite have Lena Headey
zintensity so things like that are why I
chose this as my number to number three
of course was the finale like I said the
first part of that episode was probably
one of the most fantastically filmed
sequences all season like cinematic on
the level of episode 9 but then as the
episode gets on it Peters out just a
little bit you get that really awesome
little bear moment but when you see this
on to pay off you see what's coming with
the little finger storyline you're like
ah they're gonna this is gonna be
[ __ ] drama little fingers gonna
twist
Sansa she's gonna do something stupid
she's going to cause all kinds of drama
in the north where there doesn't need to
be drama you also have this really
awesome payoff with Arya but in doing so
it kind of throws logic at the window
it's like okay you know don't pay
attention so much to the minutiae of
this really what we're
going for is Aria taking revenge for her
family in really gruesome fashion using
these awesome skills that she learned so
awesome moment a lot free pies but it
also suffers from some of the problems
of episode 9 in that it wants to get to
a big payoff but it doesn't necessarily
earn that moment and it also causes
confusion for the Jamie's storyline too
because you know you want Jamie to be
the queen Slayer because of all the
things that he's seeing Cersei do he's
like oh my god history is repeating
itself
but if Aria can jump across Westeros
with no regard for time span like if all
these timelines are moving independent
of each other timeline then how does
anything make sense so it was an amazing
episode but the execution just wasn't
quite as good to say like episode 5 or
episode 2 but hands down my favorite
finale of all time it's going to be
really hard for them to top this because
you're so excited about what's going to
be happening with Cersei next season and
you kind of have a really good idea for
where all the storylines are going you
know Daenerys is going to bring dragons
to King's Landing and just lay waste to
everything you know White Walkers are
coming you know Jon Snow is the king in
the north so you're just sitting there
and it's like this really awesome
Hitchcock episode where everyone's
sitting at the table there's a bomb
underneath and it's ticking you know
it's going to go off and you're just
waiting for it to explode next one
episode two brands first big WTF
flashback what oh my god we're going
back to Winterfell we see Jon Snow's
resurrection which wasn't as big of a
surprise because like if you've read the
books then for about the past four or
five years you've been like yeah he's
definitely coming back there have been
so many people that have been
resurrected
beric Dondarrion has been resurrected
six times no way he is not coming back
so not as much of a surprise as it was a
great suspenseful episode because you
know that he's coming back you know the
wildlings are coming because dolorous
EDD is like I'm gonna go get some help
I'll be right back and then he just goes
away for a while and you don't hear
anything you're like oh he probably went
to get the wildlings we have a giant you
guys are screwed next big pic blood of
My Blood King Slayer flashback this was
such an awesome Jamie payoff because you
hear the story in season 3 Nikolaj
coster-waldau said that when he went to
audition for Jamie and was talking to
the producers they explained they they
had to explain the character to him like
Oh Who am I going to play who's this
Jaime Lannister person they explained
his ark right up until the hot tub scene
where he explains to Brienne why it is
that he's called the Kingslayer why he
did what he did his motivation for that
in Nikolaj coster-waldau just said that
his mind was blown was like oh my god
this is such a compelling character he's
one of the best characters who you know
is good but continues to do terrible
things so you're hoping for like a
Winter Soldier civil war type Redemption
with Jamie's character which would mean
that logically he would become the queen
Slayer to save King's Landing from Queen
Cersei but you know because we have all
this Aria jumping around crossing names
off her list Cersei is on her list it
causes some confusion with that
so speaking of aria arias play was
really big in this episode I love the
play you could actually extract the play
from all the episodes and just air it as
its own episode by itself it's just so
fun the way it comments on the action of
what's been going on the past couple
seasons in King's Landing
Aria sitting there critiquing it oh no
it didn't happen this way Cersei would
be really upset she would want revenge
for the death of her son this was also
the episode that benjin came back in
anybody know also one of those moments
where the show kind of twists the books
a little so that it's an awesome TV
payoff the a vengeance back so next big
episode number 7 the broken man Jaime
versus the blackfish was so much fun the
blackfish is such an awesome character
just the way they set that up it was a
total Monty Python episode to him just
sassing him from the battlefronts just
not giving a [ __ ] about anything that
the Lannisters could possibly do to him
in it giving us our best one-off guest
character of all time there's no way
they're ever going to top this ian
mcshane is the best one-off character in
the history of the show no way that's
going to be talked the little bear does
not count because she's recurring she's
appeared in multiple episodes ian
mcshane was just in this one episode so
next bigs episode might you know my
number 7 pick episode 3 Tara joy
flashback really awesome payoff moment
for book readers really awesome set up
for show Watchers because they're like
oh my god it's young Ned Stark he's
gotten this badass fight who is that
woman crying in the tower but all the
book read it like this is a bigger book
reader episode because you're like oh my
god oh my god they're doing the thing so
if you never read the books the way we
learn about this scene is when Ned Stark
is having a dream
outed so George R Martin teased it
really early on and it's taken this long
to pay it off like people have been
wondering about it since the first book
came out and they bring Rick and start
back so that was like another big WTF
reaction at the very end of the episode
Humber betrayal oh my god they killed
shaggy-dog how dare you number 8 episode
for Daenerys unburnt awesome payoff we
also had a really awesome book moment
with Balon Greyjoy dying on the bridge
that was the most exciting thing that
happened on the Iron Islands in that
episode
Theon returning to Pike is a big plot
moment like oh my god he's come home but
for my money the bigger payoff was Balon
Greyjoy dying because in the books it's
one of Melisandre is visions three false
Kings dying one dies on a rainy bridge
and boom Balon Greyjoy being killed by
his brother but number nine picked the
premiere the reason the premiere is so
low on my list is because it was mostly
all set up there was some really funny
Monty Python jokes with the Dothraki
horselord
but the problem with them is is that
they're more caricatures than characters
meaning that they're so over the top
that you can't help but assume that
Daenerys is going to defeat them like
they just they keep rubbing her face in
the dirt you're nothing you're Queen of
no.1 we don't care about you and you
don't see drogon so you're like okay
very clearly drogon is going to show up
she's going to kill all these people
so it's almost like they threw these
horse Lords under the bus so that they
could deliver on a bigger payoff later
but finally my least favorite episode
not a terrible episode but the weakest
of the season for a couple of logic
reasons and execution in that episode 8
no one is the payoff to the Arya
storyline in while they did a lot of
interesting things with Braavos it's
really interesting place the faceless
men the house of black and white is a
really big important part of the
mythology the way the show dealt with it
was really unsatisfying like the way
arya killed the wave that happened off
screen they wanted to have the Jason
Bourne episode with her being chased all
over the streets but they didn't want to
give you the magazine kill like one of
the best kills in the Jason Bourne
series is when he kills the other
assassin with the magazine so it's just
showing you what a badass he is like he
doesn't need a weapon to be deadly so
they gave you a big
born set up without the amazing payoff
in this episode which is which is why
it's the weakest of the season it's like
okay what was the point of all this we
could have just flashed to arias
storylines seeing her training a couple
times and then had this moment at the
end where she comes back we didn't need
to waste entire episodes in Bravos for
storyline that was really just intended
to make her a hardened killer and bring
her back to Westeros so if there was any
filler this season like if you want to
say any of these episodes or filler
episodes all the Aria stuff was filler
and I feel like the whole reason why
they felt like they had to do it that
way why they couldn't just include her
in a couple scenes like Samwell was
Samwell was in like two scenes this
season they could have done that with
Arya and accomplished the same thing but
the reason I think they chose to double
down on Arya is because she's a stark
and they want to present this as like
Starks versus Lannisters in a very
binary type of way even though that's
not necessarily the way that is in the
books
they just want to tell you that the
Starks are like the protagonists in this
season was kind of like the rise of the
Starks so they felt like they had to
include Arya because she is a stark so
let me know in the comments what were
your favorite episodes of the season and
which episodes did you think were the
weakest and what you guys think about
that there's going to be some comic-con
stuff happening in the next week or two
comic-con is in about two weeks I'll be
doing a preview video for all the Game
of Thrones stuff I'll be doing don't
worry there'll be a whole bunch of
videos explaining you know what's going
to be happening because comic-con is
like this really big multi-day event
with a ton of stuff happening each day
so be sure to subscribe to get all that
stuff and there is a new round of the
giveaway now all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video it's just a $20 Amazon
gift card I'll announce the winner in
the next game of Thrones video that I
post so let me know if there's any
special bonus videos you guys want me to
do in the next week or two just let me
know in the comments while you guys wait
for my next video to post you can click
here to learn all about the azure Ahai
prophecy and how the show is messin with
you just a little bit just having a
little bit of fun interpreting the
prophecy in different ways and you can
click here for new Suicide Squad footage
and kind of a preview of what's going to
be happening at Comic Con thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight
you